this video is sponsored by mplay do you
like games trick question I know you do
if you're like me you like playing games
of all types on all your platforms
including on your phone that's where
mistplay comes in mistplay is a loyalty
app that serves several purposes it
introduces you to all kinds of mobile
games to download and play but more
importantly you can earn rewards for
simply discovering and playing games
through mplay you find a game that looks
interesting click on download play it
for a bit earn points and exchange them
for gift cards it's that simple I'm
personally I'm partial to puzzle games
or speed challenges on my phone and have
really enjoyed playing games like triple
tile or cooking Madness which I wouldn't
have even discovered much less earned
points for without mplay so if you're
playing mobile games anyway do yourself
a favor and check out mplay go to
mistplay.com Bandit or click the link in
the description below to download
missplay for free and receive 200 bonus
points for signing up today and be sure
to use my code Bandit 50 inside the app
for an additional 50 free points which
goes a long way to words the gift card
for more more details see the
description below and now on to the
[Music]
video raise your hand if you like The
Legend of Zelda are are you raising your
hand I can't actually tell there's a lot
to love about the franchise from the
characters to the monsters to the
medieval fantasy setting but what
typically goes hand inand with medieval
fantasy settings is the existence of
knights and castles and kings and Zelda
has no shortage of knights or castles or
for the purpose of this video Kings and
although the kings of Hyrule are rarely
focused on in the games leading to most
fans not really knowing all that much
about them they do each have their own
stories and impact on the franchise as a
whole sometimes even having influences
on the story that are so strong that
they directly lead to the events of
entire games they all typically appear
as the father of the princesses of
Hyrule all known as Zelda and act as the
heads of the royal family of Hyrule who
are typically Associated very closely
with the protection of the Sacred relics
such as the Triforce and the ocarine of
time another interesting fact that's
true of all hen Kings is that they're
never shown with their wives the queens
of Hyrule well all except for the latest
King that we were shown King raru but he
doesn't really count because he's a
zonai so technically he's the king of
Hyrule but not a hilan himself anyway
without further Ado let's explain each
and every one of the known hen Kings one
by one oh yeah and spoiler alert
obviously as you know if you've been
here for a bit I typically try to group
The individuals being explained in my
lore videos by their Sim ilarities for
easier scripting and understanding and
whatnot but for the kings of Hyrule I'm
just going to cover them from the oldest
to the newest according to the Canon
timeline itself which means that we will
be starting with the two kings
referenced in the game the Minish Cap
which is the first game on the timeline
that takes place in the Kingdom of
Hyrule the first king of Hyrule that we
know of from any of the games is King
Gustaf who is not among the living
anymore by the events of the Minish Cap
in life he was a friend to the
mysterious wind tribe and long after his
death even comes back as a spirit to kid
Minish capap link on his quest giving
him his gold kinstone piece which
enables link to access the wind tribe
and therefore find the wind element
therefore enabling him to you know save
the world there isn't much more to be
said about this Ancient King other than
the fact that he clearly was a good man
and ruler since his good nature even
brought him back in undeath to help save
the world from Evil he's also the
ancestor to both the current Princess
Zelda and the current King Of hyu Who is
the next up to talk about at the time
that the events of the game take place
the current king of hyru is known as
king dalus the descendant of King Gustaf
dalus has a much more active role in the
game than most of the other kings of
hyru do he's first seene at the
beginning of the game announcing the
winner of the sword fighting tournament
which fun fact he once competed in
himself and would have won if his final
opponent wasn't an equal match in skill
making the tournament end in a draw and
that opponent just so happens to be his
old friend Smith also known as Link's
Grandpa anyway he announces the winner
of the tournament who just so happens to
be vti the evil WI wizard who knocks the
king away shatters the porori blade and
turns Zelda to Stone after this the king
and Smith kind of spearhead the planning
for what to do next and decide to send
link out on this Quest because the
porori need to be contacted to Aid in
the mess and repair the porori blade and
only children can see or interact with
them and Ling just so happens to be a
literal child so what could go wrong
later on in the game the king is
imprisoned by vati who secretly replaces
him by shapeshifting into him and ruling
in his stud which some people noticed
led to the quote unquote King acting
differently meanwhile the real King
dalus was turned to stone himself and
imprisoned within the dungeon of dark
Hyrule Castle but is eventually rescued
by link via the power of the porori
blade which is now known as the for
sword he doesn't show up again in the
game after this but with link eventually
going on to defeat vti and seal the dark
wizard away and with King dalus being
rescued from his Stone imprisonment it
can pretty safely be assumed that he
also regained his proper status as king
of hyu and set things back in order
before eventually likely passing away of
old age there's no mention of a king of
hyru existing in the next Zelda game 4
swords so we'll just continue on to the
next next Zelda game the iconic Ocarina
of Time we never actually see this era
as king of hyu in game but we know he
exists because other characters
reference him directly although we don't
ever get to know what his name is well
actually maybe we do but I'll get to
that theory a bit later on unlike the
previous King dalus this King made two
Royal blunders that nearly doomed the
entire world but I'll get to those in a
second just like all the other kings of
hyu until that point he also served as
the head of the royal family and guarded
the secrets of the Sacred realm
physically apparently he was very
handsome according to this L struck lady
dancing with her significant other who
Compares his handsomeness to the Kings
politically he was a good and Fair
leader who strived for peace as some of
you may know just before the events of
arine of time there was a brutal
hyrulean Civil War that plagued the land
and cost many lives both hen and not
according to the deut Tre Sprout it was
the king of hyru himself who United the
country once again he made or maintained
alliances with the other races such as
the Zora and the gorons with Gabor the
owl claiming that the Zora served the
king of hyru and the leader of the
gorons known as darunia even referring
to the king of hyal as his sworn brother
and it's also possible that he was the
king responsible for putting an end to
the dark bloody torturous activities
done in service to the royal family that
occurred beneath the kakaro graveyard
within the Shadow Temple although that's
not confirmed and could have also been a
previous King either way he undoubtedly
was a ruler who strived for peace and
prosperity for all and was even in the
process of making peace with the desert
dwelling gudo tribe although that is
actually one of the blunders that he
made that I referenced earlier he
trusted and accepted the king of the
guto's Proclamation of falty to the
royal family of hyru even against his
own daughter's Council who claimed that
she had had a dream warning against the
man with the evil eyes and not listening
to his daughter was his second Royal
blunder these two mistakes together led
to the gudo thief usurping the Throne of
hyru and betraying the king and after
this point there's no other mention of
him in the game meaning he was likely
imprisoned I would say he might have
been executed but according to the
backstory of a link to the past the king
of hyru was around to command the seven
sages to seal Ganon away within the
sacred realm after he defeated link
which of course implies that he was
still alive also as a side note this
does mean that the next king of hyru was
technically Ganondorf dragmire himself
but there is so much story behind this
one man that I could literally make an
entire other video just dedicated to
explaining it all and that's exactly
what I did so if you're interested and
hearing the story of the usurper king of
Hyrule Ganondorf be sure to check out
this video which I will link in the
description below at the end of the game
Princess Zelda actually splits the
timeline into two leading to link
returning to his lost original timeline
before the king accepted the offer of
peace from Ganondorf and allowing link
to join forces with the princess in
warning the king of hyru to not trust
the allegiance of the gudo which
apparently was successful and led to
ganondorf's execution attempted
execution I mean the guy is kind of
stubborn okay anyway in the child
timeline we have no reason to assume
ocarine of times king of Hyrule met any
other kind of end other than old age so
at least one of his existences truly was
peaceful there's not a single reference
to any king of Hyrule for the remainder
of the child timeline so we're going to
move over to the adult timeline the next
king of hyru would be Wind Waker King
daphnis nansen hyru the last king of
hyru he's also clearly the coolest king
of Hyrule because he can turn into a
boat called the king of Red Lions which
is pretty metal well okay technically he
just takes possession of the boat by
haunting it but that's still metal as
hell for those who don't know the
setting of Wind Waker takes place long
after the ancient land of Hyrule was
flooded and buried deep beneath the
ocean this was due to the return of
Ganondorf who plagued the land of Hyrule
once again but was not met with a hero
to stop him for reasons this led King
daphnis to attempt to use his own power
to stop Ganondorf but when he realized
he was outclassed he along with the
people of Hyrule prayed to the gods for
salvation and left their fate in their
Divine hands which led the gods to
committing genocide and flooding the
entire world but before they did that
they did warn a select few chosen people
to repopulate the new world above the
waves and allowed them time to escape to
the mountaintops King daphnis was
knowledgeable King daphnis was
knowledgeable King daphnis knew about
this but he himself was not one of these
chosen people however his daughter the
Princess Zelda at the time was and
before she escaped to a Mountaintop he
split the triers of wisdom into two
pieces and gave one to Zelda keeping the
other for himself the king then remained
down in Hyrule as it was sealed away
until a few centuries later when
Ganondorf once again you know returned
this time on the surface of the new
world at this point the gods reawakened
king dh's ghost to return from the dead
and possess the king of Red Lions in
order to seek out both the new hero and
the descendant of the royal family also
known as Zelda also known as as the
pirate Queen Tetra and he does just that
locating link and aiding him on his
quest speaking ancient hen whenever
necessary and revealing to Tetra her
true identity as Princess Zelda Keeper
of the Triforce of wisdom he then AIDS
Link in his quest to restore the eight
pieces of the Triforce of courage and
even shows up for the final battle
against Ganondorf down in Old Hyrule
where he steals ganondorf's thunder
right before he got what he had spent
the last few centuries wanting and
becomes one of the only characters
across the entire franchise who is shown
to success Make A Wish upon the Triforce
and that wish is to permanently drown
Hyrule once again and create a new
brighter and better future for the Next
Generation after Ganondorf is defeated
once more and turned to stone his
descendant asks him if he would come
with them but he reveals that deep down
he and Ganondorf were the same person
neither of those old foes could let
Hyrule go and so he decides to stay
underneath the waves but this time
forever now there are a couple theories
to mention regarding daphnis nansen
which are not proven but are very
interesting nonetheless and can be
believed if you so choose to the first
of which is the theory that he was
instrumental in creating a second master
sword which is the one link uses in Wind
Waker it's a whole thing though so there
will be a link to that video also in the
description if you're interested the
second theory was brought up to me by my
good buddy in Discord mod ran the llan
historian and it reveals the possibility
that King daphnis nansen hyru actually
is the king from Ocarina of Time this is
speculative of course but if you look at
the portrait of the old Princess Zelda
within hyrell Castle you can see that
she doesn't have the same design as the
current princess Tetra instead get this
the old Zelda is pictured wearing the
exact same headpiece armor gloves tabard
and even the pink dress that Zelda from
acarina of time War implying very
heavily that this is in fact that Zelda
Ocarina Zelda and with this being an
ocarine of time portrait and the statue
of Link present within the castle being
the hero of time also from ocarine of
time it would make sense that the
acarine of time imagery would then carry
over to the portrait of King daphnis
located here if this is true and King
dhis is the very same King that once
made a mistake in trusting ganondorf's
promise of falty it makes the struggle
between Ganondorf and the old King much
more impactful it makes their jointed
Destinies that end together once and for
all down in Old Hyrule one of the most
poetic things I've ever heard but like I
said you can believe that way or not if
you so choose to as you could guess
following this game Hyrule is a
officially forgotten about and new hyru
is instead founded some Years Later by
link and Tetra even though new hyru
still has a royal family and a Princess
Zelda there's no mention of a king of
new hyu anywhere which doesn't mean
there weren't Kings of new hyru but it
does end our coverage of the adult
timeline here over in the Fallen
timeline the first game that takes place
is a link to the past and one of the
first things it shows is a dead King yep
there's his bones on his throne the
story behind this though is that after
the events of Aro time when Ganon kills
Lincoln instead of the other way around
Ganon gets sealed away within the sacred
Realm by the command of the current King
of the time which again was possibly
King daphnis nansen hyu a long time
later though as hyru had forgotten all
about Ganon and the Triforce and was
prospering under the reign of this
unnamed King strange misfortunes began
to take place like fires and earthquakes
to the point to where the king tried all
the known Magics of the world to stop it
but to no avail he then issued a reward
for anyone who could figure out how to
stop these plagues which led to the evil
wizard Agony stepping forth and quieting
all the misfortunes with previously
unseen magic the King was delighted and
immediately promoted the wizard and his
unknown Magics to the second highest
position in the land adviser to the king
yeah blind trust is apparently something
the kings of Hyrule all have in common
the Wizard's true identity however was
none other than ganon's alter ego and
his intentions were actually to destroy
the seal on the sacred realm releasing
Ganon into the world once again to
accomplish this he deceived the king
into finding and retrieving the
descendants of the seven sages known as
the maidens but before he got to the
final Maiden The Princess Zelda herself
he straight up killed her father the
king as he sat upon his throne obviously
the king doesn't do much in the game
after this but he does have a happy
ending though at the end of the game
link defeats Ganon and retrieves the
full Triforce making a wish upon it to
write all the wrongs that Ganon had
managed to accomplish one of which was
the killing of the king of hyru this
wish brings the king and even Link's
uncle back to life and they assumedly
live happily ever after the next time a
king is mentioned is all the way in
Zelda 2 The Adventure of Link which
takes place at the end of the Fallen
timeline although the king that's talked
about in this game is from long before
the events of the game likely placing
this King between the events of A Link
Between Worlds and the original Legend
of Zelda his tomb can be found in the
game but most of his story actually
comes from the game's official manual
which explains the backstory in the
backstory of Link's Adventure we learn
that this also unnamed King was fathered
to both a a son and a daughter named you
guessed it Zelda and ruled over the land
of Hyrule with the full power of the
unified Triforce at his disposal which
he is said to have mastered actually
it's said that there was a long line of
kings that all used the Triforce in
order to preserve order in the land
which is why I believe this backstory
most likely took place after A Link
Between Worlds anyway at the end of his
reign as he anticipated his death
however he realized that his son the
heir to the throne was Unworthy of the
Triforce power and that it would likely
cause the land to fall to evil if
inherited which complicated things
because of this he split the Triforce
into Power wisdom and courage leaving
power and wisdom within the kingdom
itself but hiding courage away within
the great palace in the distant Valley
of Death the king also handpicked the
monsters that would guard the final
peace from Intruders and cast a powerful
spell over the entire land of hyru that
would automatically find whoever is
deemed worthy of the Triforce and cause
a Triforce symbol to appear on their
hand marking them as the king's chosen
to reclaim the Triforce of Courage
before he died died he told all of this
to one person only his daughter Zelda
however he probably should have told his
son at least something because once the
prince became king and was supposed to
inherit the Triforce the guy kind of
freaked out when he couldn't find the
final piece and was told by a random
mysterious magician very reminiscent of
Agony that the king had actually told
his sister Zelda where the final piece
was which was true it's also unknown how
the magician knew this but either way
this led to both The Prince and the
magician ganging up on Zelda trying to
force her to tell them where the final
piece was hit but Zelda did not give in
and refused to betray her father's trust
then the magician cast an eternal
Slumber spell on the princess which made
the prince King freak out even more
because he was like dude that's way too
far which prompted him to try to stop
the magician but to no avail and after
the spell was cast the magician falls
down dead the prince King was so
regretful and distraught at his actions
leading to his sister's Eternal Slumber
that he placed her inside a room that
only the shica could open and decreed
that from that time onward every fale
female Born Into the royal family would
be named Zelda in order to never forget
the tragedy this account is referred to
as the Legend of Zelda at the time of
the games events it's unknown if a
current King is ruling over the land as
there is never any reference to royalty
other than the princess herself in both
Zelda 1 and 2 which ends our coverage of
the kings of the known Zelda Timeline
but that's not the end of the kings of
Hyrule as you know perhaps the two most
famous Kings of the land have come from
the two latest Zelda games breath of the
wild and tears of the Kingdom however it
is still unknown how the games existing
within the era of the wild are connected
to the Canon timeline if at all so I
saved them for last and will not really
be referencing any of the previous
franchise lore when explaining their
stories the first King of the Wild and
last king of Hyrule to date would be
king Ram bosphoramus Hyrule who was also
the first person link talks to after
waking up from his hundred-year nap if
there's one thing to be said about Rome
it's that he made a better leader than a
father and more on that in a second not
much is known of his marriage to the
queen or his early life before Zelda's
birth but once his daughter was born he
decided to name her Zelda in keeping
with the Royal tradition and to also
begin writing in a journal which is
fortunate for us Lord delvers he also
just directly tells link plenty of his
own story with regards to holl's
destruction 100 years ago and Link is
able to unlock his own memories of the
king through placing himself in familiar
environments across the land from what
we can gather the King was a fine ruler
who wanted the best for his people he
was told by a mysterious fortune teller
that the ancient demon Calamity Ganon
would one day soon return and that the
power to oppose this evil lies dormant
beneath the ground with this being the
king's primary focus he immediately
ordered large excavations of the land
across Hyrule which directly led to the
unearthing of hundreds of shika
constructs such as the Guardians and the
giant Divine beasts with these clearly
being weapons of mass destruction the
king ordered the shika to research the
ancient Technologies and attempt to get
them up and running which caught the
attention of his young daughter Princess
Zelda who according to the king had a
knack for research even when she was
less than 6 years old old around the
same time he and his researchers
discovered that there was once a
princess with a sacred power who
appointed a knight chosen by the master
sword and that together this ancient Duo
and only this Duo was able to seal away
the Calamity and just as he began to
realize that salvation for the people of
Hyrule through their princess was once
again made manifest in his own daughter
his wife the queen passed away suddenly
at this time Zelda was only six and
according to his journal her father
expressed concern regarding his ability
to raise her into her difficult future
as the princess of Hyrule now that her
mother and teacher had passed away this
is where he began to make certain
decisions that have garnered not a small
amount of hatred from the fan base
towards his character he began to force
Zelda to train to hone Her Sacred Powers
according to his journal he even had her
traveling to the fountain at the age of
seven in an attempt to unlock her powers
expressing a regret and pushing her so
hard and a fatherly desire to ease up on
her and tell her to just take her time
but admitting that with the Doom of the
entire world hanging above his head as
king he felt he had no choice but to
order his beloved daughter to train
relentlessly after 10 whole years of
fruitless training tensions between the
king and his daughter were at an
all-time high and even more to Zelda's
dismay the king appointed a young Knight
of her same age to her side who just so
happened to have gone and drawn the
master sword a few years prior making
him a clear candidate for you know the
Knight chosen by the master sword he
also appointed four notable Warriors of
the races of hyru to together with Zelda
and her Knight form the Champions and
each mastered the control of a Divine
Beast Zelda was appointed the leader of
the Champions and at this point all of
the pieces of the prophecy were coming
together all except for one the sealing
power of Princess Zelda this led the
king to believe in his desperation that
it was her focus on Research that was
keeping her from focusing and unlocking
the final piece of the prophecy and
saving everyone's lives and so the
events of the infamous father and
daughter memory took place which
entailed Rome confronting Zelda about
her research on her day off very sternly
and very strictly officially forbidding
her to have anything to do with the
shika Technologies until she unlocked
her power and truly watching the scene
is painful all it accomplished was to
further frustrate embarrass and stress
the princess who was still ultimately
unable to unlock her powers even after
all this time the king then wrote in his
journal that he understands his
daughter's feelings and that his heart
breaks for what she's going through he
also would love nothing more than to
console her but he believes that to be
weakness and perseveres in his heart to
quote unquote stay strong and push her
even if it means she comes to despise
him on his daughter's 17th birthday she
finally embarks to the spring of wisdom
and the King admits that this is the
last ditch attempt to unlock her powers
and that he has full intentions on
removing this burden from his daughter
should this final chance once again
prove fruitless he also had plans on
allowing her to return to her research
and that after 10 years of a strained
relationship ship he just wanted to see
his daughter return not as her King but
as her father little did he know though
that when she left for the spring on her
17th birthday that would have been the
last time he ever saw his beloved
daughter as she descended from Mount
lanu Calamity Ganon awoke suddenly from
Deep beneath hyal Castle immediately
capturing every shika construct and
killing thousands of hens her father
included Zelda still loved her father
deeply and the knowledge that her power
not unlocking led to his death further
away on her conscience it's a wonder
that she didn't break completely however
as you know just as she was about to
lose the last person who also meant the
most to her link her powers awoke within
her at that very moment and she was able
to save his life by commanding a couple
remaining shika to transport him to the
shrine of Resurrection after which the
princess headed to the castle and used
her power to confine the Calamity within
hyru Castle indefinitely awaiting the
return of the Knight the king might have
been killed by the Calamity but his
regretful Spirit lingered on in the the
world waiting for 100 years living off
the land of the great Plateau
surrounding the shrine of Resurrection
disguised as a mysterious unnamed old
man in order to softly explain the story
of what happened and guide link to the
castle but this time he didn't primarily
ask link to save Hyrule instead this is
what he says I have no right to ask this
of you
[Music]
link but I am powerless
here you must save her my daughter and
do whatever it takes to annihilate
Ganon in his death he finally was more
father than King the last tie to The
Living World he had was simply to see
his daughter saved and alive and in the
end though he was unable to ever speak
with her again as was his punishment for
his treatment of his daughter he was
finally able to see that she would be
saved by link that his daughter would be
okay and this relief is what allows King
Ram BOS faramis Hyrule the last king of
Hyrule to finally move on from this
world it's also probably a good thing
that he moved on here and didn't Linger
on for a few more years because then he
would have seen you know something a bit
worse happened the final king of hyu to
discuss is also the first king of hyu or
the first king of the refounding of
Hyrule it's literally not clear which
that is as per the creators of the games
themselves so I'm not going to weigh in
on it here but according to the word of
raru himself he is the king who founded
hyru an unknown amount of Millennia ago
long before the 10,000-year-old Calamity
as you might have noticed he's not hen
he's actually azoni one of the two
remaining members of The Mysterious race
that chose to live with the hens the
other of which is his scientist older
sister minu he married a hen Priestess
known as Sonia who possessed power over
time and together they founded the
kingdom of Hyrule and traveled around
the land destroying various evil demons
placing shrines of light above where a
demon was destroyed so that their
demonic magic would dispel and prevent
the demon from reappearing according to
a brand new interview from the director
I know right like what's with Nintendo
dropping lore in interviews these days
anyway they were also the ancestors to
the current Princess Zelda though we
never see their child or children before
Sonia gets killed by Ganondorf we just
kind of have to assume they're running
around somewhere due to time Shenanigans
Zelda is transported back in time upon
picking up ru's secret Stone and meets
her ancestors face to face living with
them and telling them about how the
kingdom of hyru is in the future and
what a cute I mean capable night this
young Man known as link is through
Zelda's memories which we can see
because she cries them out because she's
a dragon because she ate her secret
Stone we can see that rahu was a good
and just King who also again ignored
Zelda's advice and believed Ganondorf
when he swore a false oath of falty to
the huan king not knowing that the
previous wave of molduga that he was
able to put down pretty easily was
actually an attack from Ganondorf in an
attempt to overthrow Hyrule albeit a
pretty pathetic attempt also this is
another Ganondorf entirely just one
wanted to throw that out there we'll
call him bad intentions Ganondorf bad
intentions Ganondorf sees this zonai
secret stone that raru used to shoot a
big laser and decides that he'll create
a phantom Ganon under the guise of a
fake Princess Zelda in order to lure
Queen Sonia out and kill her taking the
secret stone for himself which is
successful raru becomes angered at this
and grabs some extra secret stones to
give to notable Warriors of other races
of hyrel in order to power them up as
sages and ignoring Zelda's advice yet
again decides to face Ganondorf in
combat alongside his sages claiming that
if all this fails they'll leave his fate
in the hands of that cute I mean capable
Knight Zelda is always talking about bad
intentions Ganondorf now known as The
Demon King defeats every single one of
ru's sages even though they vastly
outnumbered him which is pretty badass
and in the last attempt to stop
Ganondorf from his bad intentions raru
pulls a fast one sneaks up on Ganondorf
grabs his chest and uses his own body as
a shrine of light dispelling the Demon
King's magic for as long as it takes
and this is where he stays all the way
to the present day hyru Castle is said
to have been built around the ceiling
chamber that housed raru and Ganondorf
and acted as a seal on the seal itself
but after Calamity Ganon shook the
castle up via the events of breath of
the wild the seal was weakened leading
to ganondorf's power returning and ru's
power weakening and just as his power
dwindles away leaving only his arm left
Link and Zelda discover the bodies Zelda
receives his Stone and what's left of
raru saves link from falling to his
death carrying him up into the sky
islands that have been up here the whole
time just hidden behind the cloud
barrier and binding his arm to Links
which had gotten pretty messed up after
his encounter with Ganondorf here raru
Spirit guides link while he Adventures
across the Great Sky Island granting his
arm new abilities every time he
completes a shrine similarly to Rome
spirit in breath of the wild once link
has claimed four lights of blessing from
the shrines of light around the island
raru tells link that he's exactly what
Zelda always said he was refuses to
elaborate and disappears for now after
link restores the destroyed master sword
and joins forces with the light dragon
also known as Zelda to defeat the demon
dragon also known as bad intentions
Ganondorf the spirits of raru and Sonia
appear once again to reverse the
draconif of Zelda with time and heal
Link's arm with light and once this is
accomplished the couple moves on once
and for all and disappears from this
world for good confident that Hyrule is
now in good hands with Lincoln Zelda as
its protectors given that they surviv
this fall of course I mean really they
couldn't place them on the ground
fortunately though there was this puddle
here which allowed them to survive this
fall somehow so you know all is well and
that wraps up the complete list of every
canonical king of hyu mentioned across
the entire franchise did you know every
detail did I miss something let me know
in the comments below thank you so much
for watching and really thank you for
2023 it was a slower year on the channel
due to certain reasons but there's a
whole bunch of content plann for a whole
bunch of other franchises Zelda included
so as the year comes to a close make
sure you subscribed to stick around for
all of it in 20124 and forward and if
you would be so kind please consider
leaving a like on this video If you
enjoyed watching it or at least my
efforts into making it huge thanks as
always to my Bandit crew of which I have
a new name to announce say hello to Al
dear and crows who just joined up
seriously my Bandit crew makes my day
every day and is the reason I can
continue with the channel so thank you
all so much that's all I've got for this
one so be sure to follow me on my
socials and I'll see you next year this
is Bandit wishing you a happy New Year
and signing out
[Music]
peace